Because government I wrong the people
you know,
I believe in government.
There are things that can't do of
course,
but I think the government has had a
positive effect in the lives of millions
of people and yet no matter where you
fall on the political spectrum,
it's hard to argue with those who
criticize government for the way that it
allocates and spends the money that it
takes out of our paychecks.
The US government is a vast bureaucracy
prone to waste and redundant spending,
and this is because it doesn't do what
most of us would consider to be common
sense.
It doesn't make decisions based on
evidence or setting priorities and
making sure tax dollars are spent
wisely.
American can be compassionate and
responsible at the same time.
Let me just give you an example of what
I'm talking about.
In 2005,
George W Bush signed the deficit
reduction act and that bill set up a
council to figure out how many federal
programs we're spending money on,
things that were actually working.
The council found that for example,
the government was funding 105 stem
education initiatives totaling
$3,000,000,000
in 2006 of those 105,
only 10 pet evaluations that were
scientifically worth a damn,
and of those 10 just for were found to
be effective for out of 105 for
$3,000,000,000.
You can find ugly statistics like that
all throughout the government and the
reason is because spending decisions in
Washington and in the states too by the
way,
are made on things like costs on public
opinion,
on the pressure from lobbyists and on
the particular political ideology of
parties and politicians.
In other words,
everything but evidence.
I mean you read essays on evidence based
policy and you invariably come across
sentences like the rise and promotion of
evidence-based orientations within
government agencies is consistent with
the public sector's increased interest
in efficiency and effectiveness as if
before they were primarily concerned
with inefficiency and ineffectiveness.
Back to the video.
Everything about life in our
technocratic society is hyper efficient.
I mean,
Google just came out with a function for
web searching within the messaging APP
because switching apps is,
you know,
like really unproductive.
I think the feeling is that we're
getting more efficient by orders of
magnitude while government is just
taking a lot of time switching between
apps.
The result of that is frustration and
the result of frustration is one of the
great sleazebags of our time.
Why can't we use science and evidence to
improve government?
How would it even work?
Well,
applying evidence to social programs
involves a few things,
but the most important is something
called randomized control trials.
This means randomly selecting a large
number of people,
splitting them into two groups where one
group gets the benefits of the
programming question while the other
group,
the control group doesn't and these
groups aren't monitored over a long
period taken from medicine.
Randomized control trials are the gold
standard for determining how effective
something really is.
A government can apply this to policy by
offering money only to the programs do
this kind of research and by attaching
the condition that scientifically
rigorous evaluations must be kept up
over time or the money will disappear.
Now,
of course,
if you're going to go down this road,
you have to be willing to hear results
that you might not like.
One of the most rigorous studies ever in
this field,
for example,
was the head start impact study plan
during the Clinton years implemented
during the Bush years and reported just
before Obama's reelection in 2012.
The study found that headstart,
the program that aimed to help children
in poverty had by the end of the third
grade,
very few impacts in any of the four
domains of cognitive,
social,
emotional health and parenting practices
at a cost of $8,000,000,000
a year to the taxpayer.
Those were pretty shocking findings.
Now,
the question is,
does poor spending mean that funding
should be cut for poverty programs so
that we should scale back on stem
initiatives?
I don't think so.
In fact,
I think we should increase spending on
both,
but the money should be given to stuff
that works.
I mean that just makes sense and we
asked.
Today is not whether our government is
too big or too small,
but whether it works where the answer is
yes,
we intend to move forward where the
answer is no programs will end.
Major Kudos has to be given to the Obama
Administration for facing the headstart
results squarely and ordering a full
review of one of the signature pieces of
liberal legislation in the 20th century.
In fact,
evidence based policy has been a
cornerstone of the Obama agenda in some
key areas.
There have been some major wins by using
a competitive model of funding that
requires strong standards of evidence.
You know,
evidence based policy doesn't work for
everything,
but that any administration managed to
shoe horn science in among the other
legislative pressures is a major
accomplishment.
Of course,
you won't ever hear about
accomplishments like this on the news
because this stuff is incredibly boring,
but that's part of the problem.
Under the sensationalism of the media
and the squabbling of political parties.
There is a deep,
boring ocean of governance where
tedious,
but crucial work is being done every
day.
I think it's part of our responsibility
to wade into that ocean every once in
awhile and tune out the noise.
If you do,
who knows,
maybe you'll find something in there
that'll make you believe in government
to everybody.
Thanks for watching.
I have to give a heartfelt thanks to
everybody who supports this gentle on
Patrion by pledging a dollar or $3 per
video because that allows me to put a
lot of work into a video like this with
ideas that I think are important and
fascinating,
but not very click bait,
so thank you for that freedom.
I don't take it lightly and I'll see you
guys next Wednesday.